[موسيقى]
أعود إلى منزلي بعد أن أملك
أمضى بضعة أيام في نورماندي مع
الآباء وأكتشف بريدًا إلى
انتباه وسائل الإعلام التي صنعتها هذا
الذين استحوذوا على شانيل وقاموا بتوطينهم
الصينية وداخل هذا نفسه
أرسل إلى نظري مغلفًا بالبريد
نادية المنطقة أنا سرية وهذا هو
هناك قرأت هذه الرسالة المكتوبة بخط اليد
وهي رسالة تهديد بالقتل
أول التهديدات الموجهة إلي
قيل لي أننا سنذهب إلى الشكل الخاص بي
ملء عقلي ثم أنا
لا تجرؤ حتى على قول كلمات بذيئة هنا
لكني الآن أتعرض للإهانة كثيرًا
النساء اللواتي يرتدين الحجاب ثم
سيقول المؤلف تدريجياً أنه سيفعل
تعقب الثلاثة ملايين
والمسلمون في فرنسا وذلك في ستة اشهر
لذلك فمن المعقول رياضيا
من الواضح أنه مشروع هجوم أو
قررت الإبادة في الواقع
المسلمون يتابع ليقول ذلك
كلنا سننتهي برصاصة
في الرأس
[موسيقى]
أستشير الصحفيين
اسألهم ماذا يفعلون
هل من المهم التحدث عنها
علنًا لأن حقًا
الجالية المسلمة في شرق فرنسا
حاصرها النقاشات السياسية
وسائل الإعلام بالتعديلات
التمييز ونفس الصوت في
التمييزية ورفع
الجاذبية التي كان لها من خطورة
الأرض ولكن في الغالب لست كذلك
ليس الوحيد المعني
لذلك يجب أن أكون قادرًا على تحدي الجميع
العالم وأولئك الذين
من المفترض أن تحمينا
[موسيقى]
أوه
من الواضح أن الصحفي يرتدي أ
الحجاب تجد العمل فقط إذا
أنها تخلق وسائل الإعلام الخاصة بها خلاف ذلك
هذا غير ممكن
التطبيقات لدي لذلك نقوم باستئجار بلدي
العمل في الإنتاج مع من
كنت على اتصال لأنني
شارك في المناظرات ومتى
هو الذهاب أبعد من ذلك والنظر فيه
التجنيد وهناك صمت
مذياع
وأعتقد أن هناك مسؤولية
أيضا وسائل الإعلام التي ترفض
اختيار النساء من بينهم
الصحفيين والصحفيين من قبل
كل ذلك لأن لديهم قطعة من القماش
على الرأس لا يعرفهم
أنهم لا يقللون منها بأي حال من الأحوال
[موسيقى]
أوه